des mères qui n'en peuvent plus comme
julie monette qui s'occupe de son fils
de 8 ans lourdement handicapée monsieur
c'est une maladie neurodégénérative qui
est rare et incurable
une maladie qui l'a frappé à l'âge de 5
ans et parle puis marche put your hands
à 8 ans tous à des générations ça va
être comme ça jusqu'à la fin
julie se bat comme ses autres maires
pour obtenir de l'aide des services
sociaux qui existe ailleurs mais qui est
moins disponible dans leur région j'ai
pas le droit rien que le droit 6 heures
que c'est chanceuse d'avoir 16 ans dylan
âgé de trois ans est aussi sérieusement
affectée par sa maladie très rare je
considère chanceuse lvl recevoir cette
aide précieuse à la maison mais elle a
dû faire d'énormes pressions
j'ai fait un tête à tête je me sens du
protecteur du foyer et puis au comité
interministériel que j'ai vu que j'avais
obtenu quelque chose n'agissez pas
normal
ces maires se disent des avantages et
ailleurs au québec les parents ont des
30 à 35 à 40 heures par semaine pour des
causes comme nos enfants
puis nous ici puis les mêmes accents
sion quatre heures césar y en a qui
n'ont pas du tout un des responsables au
centre des services sociaux de la
montérégie a plus maintenant le 6 admet
que la récente réforme administrative
entraîne des retards dans le traitement
des demandes
on aime mieux qu'on raconte certaines
difficultés de la façon que nous la
hauteur des angles mais avec la création
ou le duo un du sismi on a bon espoir de
pouvoir viser journaux en attendant il
vient julie tente de se tirer d'affaires
tant bien que mal ça implique que j'ai
et mathieu qui paye 50 livres dans mes
bras je le sors du lit décembre je le
fais manger ça prend au moins une heure
à le faire à manger chaque repos
les couches le bain c'est l'enfant qui
n'ont pas abandonné l ademe avait juste
metteur en plus légère issigeac
bissonnet radio-canada saint lazare